[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 je vous
souhaite une excellente année 2024
qu'elle soit heureuse et pleine de
réussite je suis ravie de vous retrouver
pour votre 78 nous sommes le mardi 2
janvier voici le programme de ce soir
certains zvelinois figurent dans la
liste des 352 personnes distinguées par
la Légion d'honneur dans le reste de
l'actualité ivelinoise également ces
mères qui souhaitent leur vœux en
chantant ou avec leur avatar mais aussi
les communes qui ont gagné le plus
d'habitants ont fait le point en début
d'émission les gorilles les lémuriens ou
encore les Panthères sont ravis de
pouvoir profiter de nos sapins de Noël
sur source de curiosité pour jouer ou
pour se nourrir les animaux du zo safari
de toiri s'en donnent à cœur joie cette
année de grandes enseignes ont décidé de
donner leurs invendus au parc animalier
une initiative écologique et utile
avez-vous déjà pris vos bonnes
résolutions pour l'année 2024 manger
plus sainement passer plus de temps avec
ses proches ou encore faire plus de
sport ces trois résolutions arrivent en
tête de liste alors pour vous aider à
les tenir nous sommes vous allez
demander à un coach sportif de nous
donner trois exercices pour se remettre
en forme voilà pour le programme de ce
soir mais tout de suite je vous propose
de faire le point sur les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines deux maères une ancienne
députée un pompier et un astronaute
décoré quatre ivelinois ont été
distingué lors de la traditionnelle
promotion du Nouvel An de la Légion
d'Honneur jean-if Perro maire de marli
roi conseiller maître à la Cour des
comptes é élevé au grade d'officier la
maire de La Boissière école Anne
Françoise Guillot est faite chevalier
dernierre élu distingué Françoise
Descamp Cronier député PS de la 8e
circonscription des ivelines entre 2012
et 2017 elle a été nommée chevalier sur
proposition d' Rore berger des
engagements reconnus aussi du côté des
pompiers Stéphane mot le directeur
départemental du 1078 est promu
Chevalier dernier rve Linois récompensé
Jean-François clairvoois le spaonaute
français accède quant à lui au grade de
commandeur il a passé 28 jours dans
l'espace à l'occasion de trois missions
qui dit nouvelle année dit vœux et les
ivelinois rivalisent d'imagination pour
les présenter à Verneuil sur scène
fabien aurcheteur a fait appel à son
avatar une vidéo 100 % intelligence
artificielle pour illustrer notamment
sur le risque des deep fake coutumier du
fait Carl olive a une nouvelle fois
choisi vidéo etchamp pour célébrer 2024
avec le regard vers les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques
chante la vie
chante comme si tu devais mourir
demain comme si plus rien avait
d'importance chante
oui
[Musique]
chante toujours plus de nouveaux
yvelinois le département reste le plus
peuplé de la grande couronne d'après les
chiffres de Linc entre 2015 et 2021
l'augmentation est de + 0,3 % il y a
donc désormais 1,45 million d'ivelinois
la ville connaissant la plus grande
croissance c'est sacir l'école avec 2,4
% d'augmentation
démographique près de 250 cartes de
démarrage dérobé un employé de l'usine
Renault àlin sur scène a été interpellé
le 29 décembre au soir le site était
sous surveillance depuis plusieurs
semaines selon nos confrères de cette
utctu l'employé devrait être jugé
prochainement au cours d'une comparution
sur reconnaissance préalable de
culpabilité
après Noël de nombreux sapins restent
invendus dans les grandes surfaces mais
au lieu de les jeter à la déchetterie le
zoau safari de toiri les récupère pour
les offrir aux animaux gorill lémuriens
pantherèr ils en raffolent c'est
l'occasion pour eux de changer leurs
habitudes et d'éveiller leur curiosité
le reportage de Gabriel
Gontier c'est bon allez on y va c'est
parti Noël est terminé mais les an du
zoau de Toir n'ont pas fini d'être gâtés
cette année encore pour lutter contre le
gaspillage le parc a récupéré les
invendus des pépinières pour les
redistribuer à ses animaux j'ai préparé
du coup maintenant des morceaux de
poivrons comme ça qu'on va mettre dans
les branches voilà c'est ça en style
décoration et puis et pu après ça sera
tout bon pour l'enclos d'goris ce sera
sapin agrémenté de poivrons l'objectif
attirer l'animal en mobilisant ses sens
ao
Tambo à peine déposé les sapins
rencontrent un vif succès mettant en
éveil la curiosité et la gourmandise des
[Musique]
Goris et pour les carnivores aussi les
sapins représentent un intérêt là les
panères elles vont pas le manger sapin
étant donné que c'est des carnivores ça
va pas les intéresser mais par contre ça
va créer d'autres comportements et c'est
tout l'intérêt de l'enrichissement c'est
d'apporter une modification à
l'environnement d'avoir des stimulies et
de répondre à des comportements naturels
de l'animal on se sert du support du
sapin pour cacher de la nourriture pour
étaler du sang sur les branches et en
fait ça va stimuler la panthère à aller
chercher ses morceaux de viande à
l'intérieur il suffit juste de le lancer
donc je le passe par-dessus et ensuite
on va laisser les animaux s'y intéressés
l'objectif de ce partenariat avec les
grandes enseignes des alentours recycler
les sapins en leur donnant une seconde
vie gracieusement ils nous ont demandé
si on pouvait les récupérer donc c'est
quand même plutôt chouette ça donne une
seconde utilité à des sapins qui
finalement étaient destinés à partir à
la poubelle si tout n'a pas été mangé
dessus on peut les récupérer les broyer
et après ça nous sert à faire un couvert
autour de de nos massifs floral ou au
pied des arbres pour garder un maximum
de d'humidité et euh de minimiser les
Arros qu'on devrait faire normalement
sur la végétation ici sur le parc seule
contrainte pour pouvoir être redistribué
aux animaux les sapins doivent être
naturel le parc a déjà reçu une
vingtaine de dons de la part des
enseignes partenaires pour le plus grand
plaisir des pensionnaires du
parc avez-vous pris de bonnes
résolutions pour l'année 2024 c'est la
question qui peut fâcher en ce moment en
tête de liste chez les Français on
retrouve le fait de passer plus de temps
avec ses proches de de se réserver de
vrais moments de détente ou encore de
pratiquer une activité physique
régulière alors pour bien démarrer la
nouvelle année Régine ralèche et Maxence
de lacoué sont allés voir un coach
sportif pour vous expliquer trois
exercices
regardez bonjour je me présente je
m'appelle Floriant marilus et je suis
coach sportif depuis 7 ans alors
aujourd'hui on sait que après les fêtes
on a tendance à faire quelques petits
écarts c'est pour cela que je vais vous
Pr présenter trois exercices
polyarticulaires donc ça veut dire qu'on
recrute plusieurs articulations qui vont
vous permettre justement de puiser dans
les réserves et brûler un petit peu les
[Musique]
graisses alors je vais vous présenter le
premier exercice l'exercice des squat
que tout le monde connaît c'est un
exercice qui va vous permettre de bien
solliciter les membres inférieurs où on
va venir placer les pieds largeur des
hanches les orteils légèrement vers
l'extérieur et on va pousser tout
simplement les fesses vers l'arrière en
faisant une flexion de jambes comme si
on voulait s'asseoir sur une chaise
pour le deuxième exercice je vais vous
présenter cette fois-ci l'exercice des
fentes un exercice aussi incontournable
qui vous permet toujours de travailler
sur les membres inférieurs où là on va
avoir un pied devant l'autre et
l'objectif ça va être de fléchir sur la
jambe arrière pour approcher le genou
vers le sol on fait toujours bien
attention à garder le corps bien droit
et de bien engager les
[Musique]
abdominaux pour le troisème exercice
cette fois-ci on va parler du développer
couché cet exercice va vous permettre de
solliciter les muscles supérieurs du
corps donc là on va engager
principalement la poitrine les pecs mais
on va aussi avoir les épaules et les
bras il faudra tout simplement
s'allonger sur un banc essayer de
retenir et freiner la descente pour
approcher la barre vers la poitrine et
ensuite on vient pousser vers le
plafond voilà maintenant que je vous ai
présenté ces trois exercices n'oubliez
pas les facteurs essentiels qui sont la
récupération l'alimentation et
l'hydratation surtout prenez soin de
vous et c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais avant de se quitter je
vous propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
demain demain matin le ciel sera
toujours bien couvert au niveau des
températur il fera 9°gr à mant la jolie
et 10°r à Houdan Versailles et
rambouillé demain après-midi météo
France annonce des orages sur l'ensemble
du département soyez prudent côté
température il fera 11° à rambouillé et
12°gr à Oudan mantel-ajolie et
Versailles le vent sera toujours bien
présent attendez-vous à des rafales
d'environ 70 kmh et demain nous fêterons
la sainte jeunevève c'est la fin de
cette émission merci pour votre fidélité
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur
tv78 prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous
I